you
tricky night war zone points and time
handicapped I'm not quite sure how this
works exactly I don't even know how my
rook works okay can you damage my
structure it's still the same thing
applies really you just got to win and
win fast where does my LightSquared
Bishop think he wants to go maybe I
should close things up let's try that
and let's let's build a Center and do
what next okay I'm gonna back up Castle
maybe f4 maybe okay take King to g2 and
then
yeah I'm not taking that I want you to
take me okay I'm gonna do this he's a
big dummy on g3 but I have sneaky ideas
first let me hit the knight chase him
away if not here I take the bishop huh
that's sneaky this was my idea though if
my bishop wasn't captured I will
eventually get to that weakest square on
the black side but let's not jump there
just yet maybe I should have done a
different capture before that move I
don't know if that was best let's play
here maybe just well let's jump in now
with check I'm gonna take like this and
I should have done that move and play
rook age for a pressure on this night I
gotta be careful though okay now I could
do this there would have been some
tricks here I could have taken that
night already
what about smashing through on f5 that's
gonna be my plan even if it's wrong I'm
gonna smash through well I don't know
about now but take with the pawn okay
you got to take me soon and okay now
we're gonna try something crazy get my
queen really active let's get rid of
this pond so the knight does not have an
outpost on c4 and now these guys are
very very fast why did I do that oh
they're gonna take their 3.6 seconds is
not a lot for them though
I have more time okay grab that pond
okay and now go fastback determine how
many points did I get oh oh man I live
and learn right the first time that I
created ah man
there's no way I'm getting first I guess
the bigger difference between ratings
the more points you get for your wins
there's gonna be people with five six
hundred points oh my goodness I got six
yeah I I forgot to I change this ID well
actually I didn't even see the setting
it should just be time handicapped not
points handicapped but I'm still gonna
try to have a flawless victory
Mortal Kombat style age five well I'm
just gonna pick up the dark square
bishop and then get castled my bishop
wants to be on this diagonal soon hit
that rook with the pin
oh no I shouldn't have done that
let's take here they could have taken
and then there was stuff on this square
my bishop needs to stay put
never ever even think about moving from
that square otherwise yeah okay I need
to take that night out I can't allow
this bishop to even be challenged this
might be a move and if takes if takes
then I have this this square here I'm
not even sure if that does I need a
flight square still let's take my queen
I need to watch over this I want to
double up I can't allow that night to
get active okay I've stopped any night
pivots on this square I could probably
push or take let's get a flight square
for my King there's also this move or
this one I probably could have done that
now I still have enough pieces on that
so here no matter what piece captures
let's give a check here no matter what
time should not be an issue points are
gonna be a big problem
points are gonna be a big problem on the
rook Queen trade and then lock it down
let's throw in a check and play here
take with the pawn all right let's try
again they're in check let's just do a
pawn push here close to me back to
tournament 130 I'm just gonna try for my
own little confetti in a way I guess the
plan here is to try and win all my games
back to Jeremy can I do it
130 128 120 ah there's not that element
of excitement I'm not I want to be able
to be fighting for first but they can't
have that points element it has to be
time handicapped only all right you
already said that whoa now that is
crazytown
that is definitely crazytown that's
close to the fools made if this pun was
still on its home square that's that's
what you call GG back to tournament I
didn't get any points for that that's a
problem let's see if somebody could even
hit over 500 points or even 700 that
might happen I want to see who's up
there I want to see who's uh who's in
the lead let's see who's gonna be the
winner of this tournament because we
know who's not gonna be the winner we
know who's not gonna be the winner
anybody that has a very high rating life
is difficult that's just how it is
that's how tricky it is maybe that and
that's the big trick with this
tournament that's the big trick all
right let's chop here he's in a pin he's
still in a pin can't take here and this
is trouble at the very least I could
work on this structure but I could hit
him with the night fork and now what
this is just a this is a full rook I'm
gonna take here first and only then
capture the rook I'll take the Queen's
off first and he's gonna run away can't
really stop that it's a free piece right
here and then let's just trade
I already have a flight square you take
my night you get mated pre-move that's
mate back to tournament I got zero
points for that my goal is to get 20
points yeah mr. cube is saying Oh what
is put the point system yeah that's
tough zero back to tournament I got six
wins I'm six out of six 221 Oh 221
points is first mmm all right
that's a free pun and this is a very
well not a very bad structure but it's
uh it's deficient now structure wise on
the Queen side and it's take with the
Queen I'm on this square twice now see
five I take I guess Bishop check next
could also do queenside castle there's a
fork right around the corner on c7 33
seconds
yeah if okay I can take that night to c7
mmm I guess we'll do this and drop back
and then probably do this move or even
castle with check yeah unless King to e7
this is close to me they should check
here no no no not necessarily if King
here I take the rook I want to take the
rook no matter what this will be a time
when the very least route to d1 next
there should be a mate if the knight
moves grab this guy they're all
protected I guess rook here where's the
main the bishops gonna sneak back here
one day one day let's grab here no time
I'm gonna get zero points for this one
back to tournament seven seven out of
seven to 58 there's that's we're not
even 10 minutes into this tournament
the blue tuna all right let's see let's
see if we could strike at h2 this is
that it's a very humbling experience you
know you're not always gonna get rewards
for your wins are you you have to
sometimes be content with the giant
goose egg and that's exactly what's
happening here all right I have a
feeling I have a feeling Age 2 is gonna
happen
it's just a fuzzy feeling yes it's a
it's a very fuzzy real feeling 3:46 oh
my goodness that guy I think he just got
a hundred points for that win cheer him
on you go buddy let's see if you could
hit 700 Wow all right let's get
developed let's throw a pin in here I
did something similar if d6 and only
then this kicking around then there's
this sacrifice on g5 so if d6 this is
gonna be a difficult pin to get out of
yeah
chalk it up it's already a difficult pin
to get out of oh this night is getting
hammered right now 97 I take the bishop
at the very least I could get some
structural damage and maybe that's the
best I could do
let's try this open up the G file the
night is still pinned get rook here
maybe pawn pushes best to stop the
opening up of the G files top my pond
cold nope
it's not gonna happen this is gonna be
game over soon
where's the mate let's check and this is
soon to be made I could take the Queen
but I have a main threat on h6 that's
like an only move to delay the
inevitable
it's me back to German 346 267 who's
gonna catch this guy okay data data
cruncher 119 he's got 119 and I am I am
stopped cold at 10 he is will not budge
okay this Knight is uh he's having a
tough day because of that pawn push
maybe it was a slip maybe Knight to f6
they takes Knight pawn takes Knight all
right
can't get this guy now I got a material
gain even more material now with maybe
more along the way more happening soon I
was thinking there might be a fork on
that C 2 square queenside castle get my
other rook working all my pieces need to
play so let's get rolling here maybe I
should throw in a check first let's not
be so quick to pull the trigger on that
one okay now I get to take with check
hang on yeah let's go here gobble him up
whoa oh they didn't they didn't move the
rook they were supposed to move the rook
rook next time okay so they get some
material back Knight we're not anywhere
but there he's gonna he's gonna get him
now why am i giving these pieces back
this is not an on purpose not at all I
was for some reason thinking that King
could not even get on this file with
that last move all right now we're gonna
maybe go here what the fork King here
Knight c2 less than three any move back
to tournament I still got 10 it's not
gonna change 363 309 267 okay these guys
got 61 if he beats me I think I think if
I lose a game if I lose a game to
somebody I think they're gonna get a
huge huge boost with their point value
I'm curious just to do that to see
what'll happen maybe I'll do that just
for fun why not this is soup this Knight
this is probably already game over this
Knight is just too cool on f6 I could
have taken that Bishop on move earlier
that's made on g7 363 346 there is a
slight race between those two top guys
how are we doing timewise in the
tournament let me take a quick peek here
we're only at the halfway point if
Bishop here similar to what you see in
the Noah's Ark trap that
Bishop gets trapped he's gone without
the LightSquared bishop around getting
on the longest daagon on the board is
probably a good idea upon push I back up
okay let's move my knight so my bishop
could see the world and now let's throw
my knight into this square and look at
Queen h4 stuff this pawn is also pinned
and I guess we'll do that these bishops
are monsters on adjacent diagonals that
Queen his gun she's officially again all
right and can I just get my Queen
activated Queen here and then others
gonna be Bishop there I guess on push
let's kick this night away might be an
intermediate pawn push here all right
rook on the second can't be a bad idea
let's hit that pinned piece Queen here
even if the King plays to f1 Queen here
is gonna be strong next so this night is
gonna fall and we're gonna have mate
next move h2 or g2 back to terminal and
369 363 I'm going nowhere I'm probably
gonna end up in dead last I'm not sure
how many players are are in this
tournament okay create a tournament for
the first time and learn what it means
to have points enabled that's not and
that's not a good thing for higher rated
players oh man less than okay I for a
second I only have 38 seconds let's go
here let's go okay this is um
potentially a very dangerous move c4
sometimes there's lines with the Bishop
takes Knight and Bishop to b4 check
let's just get rid of him and I want a
castle before Bishop d3 prevents me from
castling
of course I think eventually I could
kick the bishop away with 95 stuff but
let's just make sure I get my king
safety in there oh that maybe that was a
mouse look maybe Queen d5 probably
there's three different pieces that were
on that Square I could get hit you know
with a pin but the rook is gonna be dead
let's just take here I'm okay with
giving up some material okay
I'm gonna hang out of my queen and it's
close to me very close to me happening
there might be a cool may pawn push I
take here and then made on d8 if you
play pawn to e6 that opens up the
diagonal still that is on the car no not
quite
it's not quite on the cards now let's
see if that night runs away though okay
there should be a maid happening soon
very very soon there I'm actually there
down in time for 11:00 408 405 Wow juicy
ketchup we've been paired up before well
symmetrical English everybody wants to
see this this is where the excitement is
fireworks everywhere I played this in
the bullet blaze Cup earlier okay my
opponents going for a quick b4 advance
and I'm not in time to meet it with this
advance so what can you do you got a you
got a regroup I need to get my bishop
doing something else and just take with
the pawn
okay you take with the pawn d forward
become weakened so I'm on this I could
have taken it already
I could have already taken that one move
sooner so I'd like to get off the lights
crab bishops I'd really like to have my
Queen here and my knight on g4 and look
for me it's not really gonna hit up in
though really gonna happen maybe I get
my knight into this square right here
Knight e5 and then point at this square
the bishop has to move this is likely to
fall I would think and what's he doing
there and I'm not really afraid of any
tack he's a super defender on g7 even if
the Queen was around even if it was like
a Queen rook battery did he go to h7 and
give a check mmm no I dropped a pawn
here you could go to h7 and give a check
but after King to f8
there's really nothing great so he's
gonna fall soon I guess it's trade I
guess just a little bit now I could play
here if there's the doubling of rooks
he's a bad Bishop but he's controlling
very important pawns so now that I have
this pawn watched over I could do this
and then come over here look at my rooks
activated his throne a check go here no
matter what he's in a pin and I guess an
approved King position wise they don't
have much time
let's just get some other quick moves in
anything back to tournament 12 I got two
points for 27 for 12 okay this is so
tricky
the tricky knight or zone we got to do a
tricky night war zone take two this is
uh there's no chance for confetti
wow that was a mouse slip he meant to
Castle let's kick him out and now he's
not coming anywhere I'm up material
let's trade keep trading down and I'm
cool with that because at the end of the
day we have the position much more
simplified alright I'm not gonna open up
this F file so he's gone let's get on a
half-open file he's dropping get my
Knights this is the pawn that's in my
territory that is most annoying so let's
challenge him immediately take here in
case of f5 I take like this trade a
bunch on d4 and at the end the Queen's
are gone and all my pieces are working I
got two minor pieces advantage 23
seconds though let's see if we could be
super quick here up to c8 yeah take with
the knight of the bishop let's go with
this less than 20 this is plenty of time
and let's go here where's the mate let's
check and we got mate here here that's
me back to Germany you had to go to the
back rank there I believe mmm 483 447
and crazy high scores okay how much more
time do we have left in this
Tournament 10 minutes this is taking
forever you realize how long these terms
can be when there's when you're not
fighting for the top the top prize the
virtual paper when you're not fighting
for that virtual paper is just it's not
even worth playing to be honest man for
a second I thought he was free
not so fast okay I got a feeling kettle
Queen you should definitely fear the
fiend cutout Queen I'm not sure what
that even means Bishop d6 to c7 what's
better than having one piece on the
longest diagonal - this is what you call
a battery problems happening on these
light squares most likely yes it's
official so he and with f3 and h3 no
longer under the control of the pawn
there's going to be an accident
happening soon that is my guess
whoa hang on for a second you got
something over here you're trying to
start something you are definitely
starting something here my king could
always run he has fast legs super fast
legs rook here let's just defend I could
play here as well I need I'm gonna get
rid I don't care to give back so um I
only have ten seconds I gotta go quicker
quicker you are not going fast enough
dude this what does that move four
seconds whoa I got to be a mouse artist
he's gonna throw in checks and stuff can
I take here I had of throwing checks
Oh go fast oh my goodness 1.6 seconds
how did that happen oh man was the ten
minutes remaining that was too close
why would I let that one get so close I
was too excited about explaining myself
to emphasize a silly little battery
along the light square diagonal yeah you
really need to do that just make moves
fast who cares about that battery on the
lungs long as diagonal the board light
squares are once again mine the light
square bishop is officially excited
about pointing really at any of the
light squares in the black camp
let's take here first and let's do this
I'm gonna get rid of my dark square
bishop I don't even want the [ __ ] I
don't even want the rook I still don't
want them I want this guy okay yeah I
still don't want them yeah I don't want
him okay now if you insist I will I will
take now so I have good coordination now
with my remaining pawn structure and
this guy here you've gone far enough I
could have taken here let's take here
now on the rook I'm on this the Queen's
are off less than 20 seconds okay I got
to go faster let's just take here how
much time did I start with in this game
seems like I have very very little time
okay I'm gonna drop him all the way back
take here
detect my bishop let's just double up
where's the mate let's check let's get
out of a pin that was a better move I'm
here the pawn can move here and then
upon mate coming up on f3 just in the
nick of time I'm one move later and
would have been still me what 5544 I'm
having trouble even saying these names
this guy he's not used to saying these
large numbers here usually only goes up
to like 300 at most so seeing 500 that
is
just out of here okay let's drop back if
this night gets too crazy there might be
something against the bishop let's try
for it the Knights pin the bishops hid
Queen here drops the night Queen there
well bishops gun Knight here however is
gonna get some material back but I
should be able to track the knight down
Knight b5 I take here Knight check I
play here I'll eventually get him
hopefully
I want to remove the night so he's not
causing me any problems over here let's
just kill him play here Bishop to d6
pointed each to my main focus however is
my main focus is just to simply develop
I want to play Bishop d6 and play King
to e7 and then allow rook takes Knight
to happen soon my bishops also there to
cover f7 in case the night he wants to
run away after king to e7 knight c7 is
covered okay so something happening over
here there might be right out of left
field there might be something against
h2 whoa I didn't expect that
my queen gonna get kicked around okay we
could go with the Queen trade I'm
hitting the rook after Queen takes Queen
and I know they missed that I have a
lead clockwise here let's just pick up
the knight of course he wasn't really
doing much I guess here here open up the
G file open up the G file is the plan
all right looking for mate on g2 soon
smashing through on this square King
here that's a pin and King to H 2 this
is mate okay that's mate right there
King to G or Queen to g2 back determined
there's 106 players I'm in 81st less
than five minutes remaining five there's
two guys up there a 555 this guy is that
negative 886
what is going on here oh is this a sneak
artist oh I think it might be a sneak
artist no I should have taken that pun
maybe they meant g6 why did I do that
this guy's playing very good for her
negative 886 okay all right all right is
something fishy happening my Knights
going to do some dangerous stuff I'm on
the Queen I'm on the knight Bishop h7
stuff I got the Queen I could take here
and kick the knight around nope
uh-huh can takes rook that's me this guy
was flying back to tournament that's
mate 593 555 504 this guy has negative
21 normally he's he's one of the guys
that are up there I'm familiar with this
guy's name all right I'm gonna throw in
a quick strike against the Queen creme
of mode no I didn't catch them in
pre-move mode that is officially a cheap
trick and a half alright let's let's try
another one let's keep moving forward
I'm all forward in those open positions
let's keep it open here have a slight
lead in development you're gonna take me
and help my development yes I want to
avoid that exchange as much as I like
having Queen trades all right let's open
up this side of the board that's where
your king is I'm gonna go after him
let's try this takes all right let's
take here close no I was ready to move
my queen in the corner she can't do that
there might be something dangerous
happening very soon like um I have my
back rank covered that's why I was
hesitating there I didn't want to take
man okay I guess we'll go for it how
much time do I have nineteen seconds I
was too fearful with my back rank yeah
did you realize how nervous I was
getting there I just I was really really
wanting to have King safety I'm nothing
without my King safety I'm just I worry
I worry a real lot without King safety
this King can't go too far all right
what's the plan here I'm gonna take
towards the center so I could at least
hide over here
hmm where can I get a pass punt okay
there we go now the wheels are in motion
and he's gone and my pond is gonna start
pushing how could I do this
I'm just keep pushing for seconds okay
grab him here why does it have to be
like this complicated keep going fast
he's cut off one two three no four that
move in 124 six eleven is top okay is
188 there's not a 180 up eighty-eight
there's not a 188 up on the board this
guy isn't on the top ten I'm really
curious to just see how many points
somebody would score if I just lost
against them I'm very tempted to do that
maybe I'll just offer a draw all right
look let's see this guy has 188 I don't
know I want to see what happens I'm just
too curious oh that's a free bishop I'm
gonna take him let's guard here I guess
complete development who cares about
that pawn 2900 Knight here just castle
no who cares about castling King here
there's not enough pieces on the board
for my king to be scared this is a
perfect home right here let's get rid of
that rook he's too active if you take on
a - I don't care about my bishop I
actually I should have I don't have that
much material what am i doing I thought
I had more material not the case all
right this should still be winning but
it's certainly a much bigger struggle
okay King and pawn in game I could win
these he's a freebie right here on the D
file all right let's track this guy down
okay now I have a runner you can't
create a passed pawn over here so he's
going to be super fast doubled pawns are
very strong defenders against pawn
islands when that up on Island is trying
to create a passed pawn okay this one
was aborted the tournament has
officially ended
and the person in first first place in
the tricky night war zone this will be
the last time I do points handicap I
didn't realize that that was the case
prior to creating this tournament the
winner is
Snow's Ivey with a whopping six hundred
and forty nine points next up is Yoshi
squad and then pawns are pawns ROP all
right and then Alex Raiders in there
with five fifth place
Ross Cole Cole Tran
all right good games Oh what place did I
get I got 79th out of 106 I'm in there
with a beefy 22 points